[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys I figured today I was going to
do a little mashup of a cozy ketchup and
reacting to your assumptions a day with
me a little bit of everything because I
haven't done like a sit-down kind of
personal video in a long time also
welcome surrending house my new life
black coffee
what I do this morning I had the best
scary June last night but I always wake
up for like the best moments like
cliffhangers and stuff like that would
be an amazing movie and I'm amazing end
of the movie so I actually woke up
started writing my dream down like I
normally do you're not following me on
Twitter from me on Twitter and you'll
see all my stories or in the discord
down below and yet I need to finish that
story now but I need the copy cuz I
don't even rain for an hour and I still
have the majority of this story to go so
hopefully I'll be done in another hour
or so and I'll be able to share with you
over Twitter and then we need to go and
do some really fun stuff we need to get
some washing-up liquid because
[Music]
[Applause]
I live with the landlady you have the
dog and she bought her dog African
Easter I get it I can't wait until you
open
[Music]
I finished my little story
no one's our fighter but yes and maybe
but let me let me give you a little a
little unserved it sorry then I guess
hurt it's Cod Tom's haunted house I have
a friend
this house is haunted by the vengeful
spirit of a girl they say if anyone
falls pregnant two lives there then the
legend goes that if the baby is known to
be a girl then the girls will make sure
that the baby will not survive along the
mother then itself where these rumors
come from you ask well that's exactly
what happened to the last tenants who
lived there a happy family until news of
a newborn baby girl started destroyed
but on the night of bath all that came
my name knew the last family well but
when I asked her about the cares of the
house she just shrugs it off there's
always a rescue take for bringing Beauty
into the world but I'm not so sure
myself thing I tell you this now because
well Thomas sister is pregnant twins
they say a boy and a girl that's
wonderful news and how much longer until
I can meet them I asked her how about
looking large enough to burst any day
now she replies warmly they're actually
a little bit late
I feel a referal of force brush against
my hand that has rested upon the bulging
bunk and looked down to notice the skin
contorted around my hand I
not wanting to offend Sally who it's
still smiley and content she never
believes in ghost stories
that's great news Sally although I
couldn't help but feel in these creep
into my stomach
I'll leave it there
Joan the discord to beat the rest of the
story or follow me on Twitter every way
let's stop wasting time I need to go to
the shops and buy some things and news
update I'm in the car but I'm not gonna
plug in the car because I don't want to
crash I'm not a real blogger help what
am i doing
we have a time from shopping I got
groceries no groceries and right now I
am parked buy a new patch of forest that
I didn't know was around my house which
is lovely so um I'll probably go in and
explore that in a little bit what's the
time yeah oh my gosh I was a 2 already
maybe not then cuz I got a live stream
soon and I haven't eaten yeah
balls where is the time go okay anyway
um time to read your assumptions of me
let's see what what a lovely lovely
things you guys think of when you think
of me um oh by the way esperan forever
putting up this yeah he's no fairy like
some of cars like it's gonna look so
cute
turns out I don't have any batteries
turn them on we fail fail fail
hey Lisa left the house today you are
sweet and kind hard-working and tries to
enjoy life as much as possible that's so
cute
I mean thank you that's that's why I
aspire to be whether it is true or not I
think that's up to other people um but
yeah I do like to try and enjoy life as
much as possible
but sometimes that leads me to not
enjoying life because I'm trying too
hard you get me that's a thing okay
number two I kind of assume you're
really sweet and fun person thank you
again really nice assumption Ciro don't
I don't know what to say haha
okay we go away up in here you're always
horny I don't know if I should put that
in the video that's not appropriate not
appropriate not appropriate not
appropriate your hair smells like
strawberries of milk is it true I don't
know no you can smell a weird stuff in
my hair so it probably doesn't smell all
that good to be honest it usually smells
like henna maybe coconut sometimes so
that's not too bad but yeah I use a lot
of oils I'm expecting someone to just
come in from the woods to my car any
second oh here's one I suppose that
you're relaxed thank you but I have
never ever ever ever ever been described
as relaxed ever no I'm not resist
I do way too much and I worry way too
much about absolutely everything so
relaxed is I am NOT but I appreciate
that I might come across as relaxed I am
relaxed when I'm tired when I'm tired I
am relaxed God you're all so nice like
you literally all so nice just my face a
little a just says I assume you're
wondering wonderful human being am i
reply is even though you're really
pretty
you don't believe people
or when they complement you that's an
interesting one thank you for the
compliment Nathan but I mean pretty it's
it's subjective it's an opinion so I
will never say someone's opinion it's
invalid or not right but I know how I
see myself and if someone else sees me
differently they can let me know that
and it's not that I'm saying like I
don't think that I'm like attractive or
or non-attractive I'm just like I'm me
if you get what I mean
and I'm I don't know i guess i I I do
have a lot of barriers in my life so if
someone talks about the outward
appearance I'm just kind of numb to it
because I don't really know what your
intentions are or you know however if
there's a compliment about something
below the surface beneath the surface
that's nice like I like that I'm not
saying that I'm not I'm gonna be
annoying if someone says you you're
pretty or like youryour face is good and
your hair is nice like thank you or
you've really appreciate that but I just
don't really know how to respond and
it's not that I don't believe them
because yeah maybe I'm just a bit like
me because you you can say it you can
just say it but then meaning it's
something different and then saying it
for what reason you just try to make me
happy you trying to get something from
me like what you want from this
situation so I guess it's like who says
it who they are to me what situation
they're saying in that was a long-winded
response how am I gonna reply on
Instagram I don't know you agree that
jaffa cakes cakes rather than biscuits I
actually do agree I think I think do i I
mean they're little like a biscuit but
you can have many cakes anyway and I
started srg their cakey they're like oh
I don't like them I don't eat them there
you go
but I do think yes they're probably more
cakes than biscuits so yes your
assumption was correct I got one here
saying play more Resident Evil I played
rather the people yesterday I'll help
you
no and that's not an assumption okay so
this one is some real stuff I resent
pretentious self-righteous and
hypocritical hey you asked okay so
actually this is quite funny that you
should say this cuz I used to worry
about this so much and it's one of the
main reasons why I do not when I meet
someone in like the real world I don't
tell people about my youtube or
Instagram or anything might do outside
of like work because I worry so much
that I'm gonna come across as an
arrogant pretentious [ __ ] so I just
keep it all to myself I think things
like thinking someone is arrogant or
pretentious or whatever that's their
opinion of someone so I can't go around
saying I have not this I am NOT that
because my my perception of myself is
probably different to how other people
see me and I don't know how I come
across to other people I'll never fully
know people can tell me but it'll
probably always have this this facade of
them not wanting to hurt me or you know
they don't actually no one really knows
who you are but they know through their
eyes from what they've seen of you and
what you allow them to see
hey color um so yeah anyway big rambles
used to worry about this a lot you can
think about you can think that about me
if you want I can absolutely see why you
would because if you only saw what I put
out online then it probably looks like
all I do is like to talk about myself
all the time but I don't do that in real
life so that's all I can say to that one
oh we've got one here you're not a
talkative person that's mmm I don't know
um it's so weird people will meet me and
they will literally either say one or
the other and I think that's actually me
as a person I am very much one way or
the other in most emotional things so
when I meet someone in a certain energy
flow I guess that's how I come across
but saying that I would say that if I'm
in a social situation and like a very
big social situation so for instance if
I go to the pub or something like that
after working there's a lot of people
I will much prefer it like maybe talk to
one person or two people than a massive
group full and then more people come the
more I would just rather stay in the
background and just listen and sip my
beer and just enjoy my beer I mean
listen better what I'll speak there's
all because I'm like necessarily shy
it's just that that's the way I like it
uh-huh uh-huh I like it yeah so maybe
that answers your question I don't know
ah my phone is on 5% battery did it did
it dude it do a bit lat to left wing but
better to be less than right yeah I'm
gonna probably agree with that hey it's
Rick then you'll play the evil within
three hell yes I'm gonna play that game
you got that perception right my man you
got that perception right you've got
that perception right right anyway um
should we quickly get out just feel like
a little bit I'll just Oh
chay-ara shake-a shake-a she
[Music]
it's a public footpath and I walk down
it and it was like private property
firing please don't hello guys I am back
at home with my cup of coffee let's have
the cozy ketchup section of our catching
ups and yes I do like coffee because
someone else assumed I like coffee I
drink it maybe a bit too much I'm trying
to keep down to two coffees a day I
don't know people say those are like
caffeine and stuff but coffee okay
anyway off off topic I probably let you
know that I am in a new place new
surroundings are like kind of brief 16
before because I got myself a job yes
there is a drop in the games industry so
it's so happy everything that I work
towards it's it's paid off and I'm I'm
loving my job it's it's a great job and
the people that are so lovely and I just
feel I feel very lucky to have it so
yeah life is good on that front I mean
the job is difficult and it's leaves me
it's leaves me very tired at the end of
the day what is hair doing but it's so
worth it and I'm just like I'm just
doing what I love it's so weird that
when I actually sit don't think about it
and I'm like but you probably wondering
what what have you got to look forward
to I come what am I going to share with
you because it is so weird Morgan why
it's so weird
doing a lot of things like drawing and
does
I work for games but not actually
sharing with you because I can't not
allowed so what have you got to look
forward to well of course I'm doing my
live streams I'm gonna try and do them
after work if I'm not too tired and I'm
doing them on the weekends as well so
you guys know that I'm very still be
playing games with you guys and also
whenever I have the chance I am still
going to be working on my own stuff has
other parts and you guys know that I
will share with you every inch of that
so that is happening I am slowly slowly
but surely working on working on the
kinks of perfection so I can update that
for you bands we have a special
announcement to make soon it's a music
announcement it's to do with the EP that
I proposed to you and I can tell you it
is so close to being done what was that
not beside just me I can't wait to share
with you some work that I've been doing
with Jaime Aldous at Horizon productions
he here turned my music into something
else something else and I just can't
wait for you to see it but I've also
been working with people back in my
hometown Plymouth to make the music
video oh yeah that's one main thing that
you guys anyway I'm not even sure if
like I will feel much more anything
else's is wish you just a little little
video for me to open up a bit to you by
answering your assumptions and take you
a little bit through some my day and
just chat with you about the stuff
that's been going on because a lot has
been going on
and I haven't really informed you about
me moving house or staying in your job
or doing all of the things that I've
been doing because I just just happen
but now you know so yeah have a lovely
evening and I'll see you in the next
live stream and keep on being hyped for
the EP because it will be properly melt
soon and by Jesus Christ the whole time
my microphone was not plugged in you can
tell I haven't done this in a while what
you gonna do about it son has bad audio
I guess sorry